firstly questions of Venice Nina
different I wanted to sleep but no we
can't we can't because this is the only
day we have in Venice okay believe
nation we're going to Venice and then on
the Greek Cruise and we're taking you
guys with us
[Music]
so we're late
Nina doesn't like it we have to get to
the airport Nina's never in the vents
we're gonna take her to Venice she's
never going to st. therese
we're going to take your Santorini okay
then I'm the remapping so that means
that's my managing statement let's get
our ride and get to the airport so don't
miss it so then when we're stuck home
yeah crazy wind warning in Toronto so
hopefully our flight at you takes off
[Music]
it's a windstorm happening here in
Toronto look my hair's going crazy
Lena's a cheese let that bad look that
bad
hi Green twist twist wit win risks so
let's see let's get a fight menace one
thing you have to get ready for when you
travel with Nina because you're always
going to get stopped at the customs
or whatever x-ray machine because she
brings a thousand bottles of creams and
lotions and whatever and they told them
about put it all in one bag and what did
she do what did you do she totally
ignored them
okay Nina's a rule-breaker she's the
real rebel they miss a big crater
[Music]
did you take it we're not late you made
it
next time don't fall asleep at the
lounge too much red wine Vanina I almost
got this leak it's okay we made it first
ones I've complained no it's shaky I did
not sleep at all in a slump a little bit
two hours we're in Venice
it's remitted Italy we made it we made
it we made it very spicy we have to
nothing go through customs
go to the bathroom find the butts to get
the Menace and then hopefully not crash
too much today those of you who don't
know I am half Italian my mother was
born in Italy I learned a little bit of
Italian growing up so every time I come
back to Italy which is like I don't know
once every five years and simply I get
the chance to practice my rusty Italian
and see if I can get by the good news is
I can always impress Nina she has no
idea the same so even though it's
massively broken Italian it still sounds
insanely impressive and sexy right right
right right
I mean this buying a SIM card so we can
use Google Maps and not rely on an
actual map so eight gigabytes eight
gigabytes for 50
no plus service fee 8 gigabytes with
unlimited maps is roughly 100 Canadian
dollars not too bad I guess
we made it onto the bus heading to
Venice from the airport did we tell
everybody why we're going to Venice why
we're going to Venice the cruise but why
why why do we pick Venice over other
places Mina's never been in the and Bly
and the way I generates very good well
one of the cruise zero these at sea
which is crazy
it hits Venice which gene has never been
to beautiful city Santorini beautiful
city name has never been to in Athens
which I've which neither of us have been
to and then I might other places in
between so it's cool that we had a
cruise trip that hit Venice Santorini in
Athens yeah we're going to meet my team
I know this it see any we're gonna meet
Kristina and in the team five at five of
my people who work for me I've never met
before I've worked for me for years
first and we're gonna meet them so not
today but on this trip and that's why
we're here and Nina's been working very
hard at work oh yeah and so she alright
too hard yeah too hard
too hard so she needs a break
that's what
[Music]
all righty we made it to Venice it's not
that bad we have to get used to the
smokers the amount of smokers is
something we're not used to as Canadians
but we've got an hour and a half to find
some Italian coffee for me and Nina get
to our Airbnb which we need to navigate
the streets of Venice so we'll see how
complicated that is and then jump up our
bikes and then go for a real exploration
[Music]
first impressions of Venice Nina
different I'm not looking at a lot of
canals everything is on the water
everything is on the water I've been
here in a long long life one of the most
unique cities in the world
with one of the most unique women in the
world garbage truck there are no cars in
Venice so this is how they do it that's
how they ship bottles of water to your
restaurant everything is done on the
boat
[Music]
we've got about an hour before meeting
their Airbnb hosts so we're gonna sit
down at a local bar cafe have some pizza
push it
well no it's almost 11:00 now for us
it's 5:00 in the morning but we haven't
slept so we're kind of on a weird time
in anyway so I don't like prosciutto in
general but Nina likes it and I'm gonna
give it a try because it's we're in
Italy so it's different than then the
Canadian style so prosciutto and
mushroom pizza with two cappuccinos
coming up and just taking in the Italian
scenery vibes chill and some cigarette
smoke - yeah this is your first coffee
in Italy have we have we been in Italy
okay right the best memories ever of
course of course amazing times how could
I forget last night I didn't sleep at
all on the night before at least up for
hours so I'm running on fumes anyway
first time the first coffee in Venice
thumbs up yeah the pizza has arrived
look at that smells smells great
mushrooms prosciutto tomato sauce and
cheese simple all right Nina let us know
just okay all right different time to
eat up
[Music]
so we got our key look at this giant key
think of this key with our key to our
Airbnb went upstairs I lay on the couch
and wanted to wanted to pass out and
Nina wanted to let me sleep hold on oh
the cigarette smoke get my allergies up
I wanted to sleep but no we can't we
can't because this is the only day we
have in Venice and I need to show Nina
what there is to see in Venice right
Nina
we're not here to sleep we'll sleep in a
few hours but let's explore first move
[Music]
okay Nina we've seen a lot of canals but
we're about to see the main canal the
main canal the big canal I'm excited for
you that we need to make your hand
purple this is the Grand Canal this is
the one all those other ones were like
the Nina one city the little ones but
actually this is the Nina one because
it's the most special one do I save it
it's what I say I feel like I saved it
and I totally saved that one coming up
[Music]
so Nina they're also known for their
their glass work see all that glass
would I know
you got any motivational words for us
Nina believe care cannoli
all those I don't know what those aren't
caramel candy it says they give the
cannoli
that's what a traffic jam in Venice
looks like no cars allowed in the city
no Vespas allowed in the city no
bicycles in the city just walking or
boats and that's how you get out to the
main canal
this is it the main plaza and the bell
tower
how we feeling right now cute a huge
mean of the tourists well I guess I'm a
tourist - I'm I've just been filming
this whole thing so sometimes this is
there's too much water
it's floods and this is all under water
and they have planks of wood you have to
walk around so we got lucky that's the
famous Church the Basilica and then the
clock bell tower you can go up and see -
up there
[Music]
this place is pretty busy with all the
people hanging out with ordering and
eating outside so Venice don't let us
down with your pasta let's see it
we're at Del Mar OHS fresh pasta to go
I'm always on the hunt for a good
chicken alfredo right Nina everywhere I
go I want chicken alfredo so we're gonna
give Italy a shot
come on Menace don't disappoint us give
us a good chicken alfredo it's right
there good okay now the real moment of
truth you met him in China I know that
afraid of what I'm after I have Alfredo
everywhere Venice
okay mr. big thumbs up Bennett's how you
feeling good yeah like tired sleepy good
yeah
like full oh oh I'm super full I wasn't
even hungry go ahead but now I'm really
full that was good
[Music]
[Applause]
well it wouldn't be a comical vacation
without a bit of rain it's not that bad
but it's spitting on us we have to last
quick stop's on day one when we're going
to get some bottled water I'm a huge fan
of Venice tap water Nina's not just a
big top on a period I do so we're gonna
get some bottled water and then we're
gonna go to yield Doge a pronounce that
Doge a doji I should know this one I
know right I'm sewing that guy's one of
the best Italian ice cream shops on the
island so I'm excited
[Music]
Teaneck underwater then let's go get
some ice cream before we get rained on
okay this is it okay we got two of their
specialties and two of my typical
favorites more basics
okay so Nina's gonna try them try all
four Nina okay Jamie it's more basic
like vanilla ish okay
and then the two specialties okay well I
think I guess I'm stuck with these oh
yeah oh my god
oh my god why did I get this it's good
too though okay
Italy Denis Wow thank you Venice for the
amazing gelato
we will Google
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good timing
[Music]
[Applause]
remember Valentina
[Music]
it's been an amazing day one thank you
guys for joining us on this if you want
to see our last crews to be curable win
with that that's Europe if you want to
see our last goose put a hair up check
out the link right there next to us we
think you'll enjoy it
if you don't believe this is dripping on
me and we'll see you soon welcome to
London
we're from Canada we can handle it Nina
don't die on your first day in London
okay